okay
for people joining this live stream we
are
doing a language completeness and
consistency meeting
getting ready for the 12-2 release of
wolfen language at least i think this is
mostly 12-2 stuff
am i right that it's mostly 12. the
first three are
well the first two are definitely 12 to
the third one is sort of borderline and
the last one is not
okay all right options
mode what the heck is all of this
right so this was we we this was
one of the ways to customize the
uh the behavior of check arguments and
arguments options where you have
um you know optional positional
arguments
and but there might be issues
right there might be rules inside
optional positional
so longest and shortest basically has to
do with the pattern
from the right hand end of the argument
sequence
right so the default behavior is
if it matches options queue or
options pattern i mean then
it's considered an option specification
and grouped with the options rather than
the
positional arguments
with um uh with options mode goes to
shortest it checks well is this
actually a known option for this
function
and makes the decision based on that but
then it's not shortest the longest it
has different names
uh well those are the names we came up
with
but maybe that's not the right
description so i mean let's look at the
check arguments page
what the heck is this options mode
the thing we're discussing oh
keys can be used for the association
okay so this is an association
right
okay but so so there's different issues
here which is
treat all unknown trailing options
so what's the question here the question
is so this is
right so if you have so the behavior we
we we have used since oivins and
you know created the internal version of
this option and version
six probably for the string guys
is if um
well in the case where you just have a
single option it's
unambiguous if it's right is this option
name a known option name for this
function
or is it not if it is then it's
an option if it's not then it's just an
arbitrary rule you feed in as a
positional argument
the problem comes what happens when you
have a list of rules
and so now you have a combination and so
what even did was essentially use an
or sort of rule so an empty list is a
positional argument
not an option specification despite the
fact that it does match
options pattern but that's sort of
important in all sorts of use cases
and the case where you have a mixture of
known and unknown options
it's treated as an option specification
but it'll just give a message saying
well and
you you've given me an unknown option
um okay what is what is it that you want
to do here
what i want to do is what i
what i am proposing is that
we for lists of things we still consider
an
empty list a a
you know a positional argument but a
list of rules is only considered
um well is considered an optional
argument and not an option specification
unless all of the left-hand sides are
known options to the function which is
a slight change in behavior but on the
other hand it
fixes examples like the one that's shown
there
with the message from string replace
um look i think we should segregate
these things more
you know
in more um uh i mean longest and
shortest is not really the right
characterization there's more to it
how so well i mean you're saying whether
they're
enclosed in a list whether they're not
enclosed in a list all these kinds of
things
well but no no because longest and
shortest refers to
which positions is are you taking the
longest possible sequence of option
specs or the shortest ones okay right
right the i mean we could i mean if you
wanted
i mean i'm not a priori uh
uh you know i'm not a priori opposed to
changing the name but i
think that uh you're slightly mixing the
issues because you are focusing on
what an individual thing is considered
what is the decision we're trying to
make here
well it's like i said
do we treat uh you know
in this case uh where we have a known
option and an unknown option in the list
does that get categorized as a
positional argument or as an option spec
which is a change in behavior but i
think it's generally an improvement
okay i think we should do whatever you
think is right okay
with these particular names and you know
if we need to break it
in more detail later we'll put more
pieces in the association and define it
more precisely
right and and you can see the possible
new description that i
that's the third bullet point i think
for
uh this was actually ian's suggestion
but i think it's a good
way which one the the possible new
document
which is supposed to be new
documentation so that's the proposed new
description for these two
values
treat anything other than one or more
known options
why don't you say treat anything other
than knowing options
because because that's ambiguous sorry
can i can i share for a second
maybe maybe no i i believe you i'm i'm
we're in the tail of the animal this
this is fine i i think the issue
if i'm remembering right is what happens
if you have known option followed by
unknown option followed by a known
option
i think i think the point is that the
current code
says oh i see a known option and so
treats
everything from that
let me just um sorry i just have to find
the right place to
give you control here
go ahead all right
okay so and here i'll make my font
much larger hopefully so
oops all right so
right suppose we we have f of
you know a and then we have you know
unknown goes to
val and
unknown goes to val
well this this get this case this case
is unambiguous
because this is not
a known option so this is a positional
argument
and therefore everything has to last at
the end now put another known at the end
and then the question is what is go
ahead no no no that's not the issue
this this case is also unambiguous
why does that get small a little sudden
um
this case is also unambiguous because
you look if you start at the right
this is a known option spec so this is
um
so this is an option spec this is a
positional argument
therefore everything to the left is
a positional argument with options mode
goes to longest
then all of these guys are treated as
options
because you take the longest ring
starting from the right
where you run into trouble is
this case you have both a known and a
unknown guy in a single slot
because right because options pattern
doesn't just match
sequences of rules so what do you want
to do in that case
so in this case i want to change the
behavior so that
this is only considered this is
will now be considered an a positional
argument because
not everything unless you say longest
right and the default is longest because
the default is don't look at the names
just
look at options look i think this should
be
sliced more thinly i think they're
different cases here
um but i i think it's okay to make that
change right now especially since this
function
has never been seen in the you know in
the system
context before so i think it's okay to
do that
but i would like to flag the fact that i
think there probably some other settings
that
will be useful okay that's fine
okay and maybe it
just for for us that use this thing a
lot in the internal context uh
is there a document anywhere that
stresses any difference that
might be introduced in the system
function compared to what was before
uh there is no difference uh the
one function takes both uh right so
basically
longest is basically what used to be
arguments
or what still is arguments in the
internal context
and shortest is what is arguments with
rules in the internal context
um and thank you yes so basically we've
packaged everything
you know the seven different functions
into one sort of nice
interface okay let's move on so the
knitting you skipped over the knitting
this was supposed to do it well uh
you said you wanted to review it when
you did then close and confirm but then
apparently you had some
meeting with just christopher and none
of us knew about it so
right okay all right let's see package
bulletproofing
does it really belong here
package development i'm not sure it
belongs it does it belong in
bulletproofing
i oh well i guess what's the difference
but this is
uh this is a way to you know
check arguments certainly yeah right i
mean it certainly makes your
you know issues more useful messages
etc oh actually we had a thing down here
well that was put in by ian
right okay let's untens to that for a
second let's take a look at that
does it return an evaluation no it's not
on its own so i think that description
is is misleading
um i think for
check for and issue messages for
incorrect arguments or options would be
a correct description
um
what about define a function there's no
defining of any function
it's not defining a function it's just
doing the checking
[Music]
um
what does this do right this is the
thing that splits it into
separate uh
arguments and options for a function
yep
okay
and he and he put in sort of a different
description here
so if we want to compare verify
oh because it's an options management
which sort of makes sense
that seems okay to me okay
um have we done see also for all these
things
yep okay good all right let's move on
excluded contacts
okay so this is most for the most part i
mean there's a little
question to a couple of minor questions
asked but this is
mainly to make sure everybody's in
agreement about
where we are and where we're going um
right so we've changed full definition
so it doesn't right so
full definition does two things it
full definition gets the definitions of
a symbol but then it also pulls in the
definitions of everything that appears
in there
and it used to have one rule which was
well don't pull in a symbol if it's
protected or read protected
and now we've added a second rule which
says well don't pull it in
if it's in one of these internal
contexts and you can sort of control
that
okay by by so the the question is how
does this dovetail with the autocomplete
stuff
the um
auto complete stuff
is manually curated whereas this is
semi semi-auto-generated it could
um i think it probably the
the the the list of exclusions does
exist as an
internal symbol and so i so included
contacts are automatic could do the
internal thing
to could do that default thing right and
that's what it does
okay fine but so so i would like to
complain and as lou here
i would like to complain about the the
treatment of
of in the autocomplete stuff is lou here
or not
although he's not primarily responsible
for that
so who is uh tom
sherlock i can convey a message if
needed
well i've already had this discussion i
know i've just been told oh it's all too
difficult but that's not good enough
um i mean it could certainly um
the truth is i should never
myself see stupid contexts that i know
perfectly well shouldn't be there
right right and i don't understand why i
am i don't know whether it's a
prestigious problem
um where people are not communicating
this is an internal context whether it's
incorrect
exporting from packages or what it is
so right now um
the um
the list is manually curated so if it's
not
communica uh well no that's not
completely true because things like dumb
contexts
are automatically excluded um
i'm here hearing background from
somebody yeah can we please
um how are you
wait a minute could somebody mute
themselves or i'm going to stand you
need to mute yourself
the pipes between the walls oh
okay all right um
so um right so anything in a dump
context or a private context is
automatically excluded if somebody
creates a new context which doesn't
uh match that pattern then it needs to
be
added to to the front end list
now this list the list i have is
sort of uh a more complicated
backing up a second we've got
development and we've got release
engineering
and we've got conventions which may or
may not have been followed
right right okay so first question is do
we know what the conventions are
can we determine from the complete
source tree what are all the contexts
mentioned in the source tree
we should be able to determine that
right um
[Music]
maybe come on i mean we just do a search
for the begins
well you have to be aware of you have to
be aware of
two things you have to be aware of the
new package format
and you have to be aware of pacliffs
right and you also need to be aware of
the fact that a
begin can be a backtick can start with a
backtick in which case
i understand i understand i understand
what you're saying what i'm saying is
what we need to do is inventory all of
those things because we're still
failing failing failing on these
autocompletes right
so some point we're going to have to do
some real work and what i would
recommend that we do
is to decide on a convention
and then implement that convention
right but i mean we
okay so i mean who does it who is it
going to take to actually do that
so it requires going through the source
tree
and you know identifying those things
right but i don't think just going
through the source tree is enough right
because some of some of the
right some some things are documented
right and so no i understand
but what i'm saying is in the source
tree there will be 4
000 contacts let's say okay
okay so now we have to filter that down
so oh this one is documented this one is
a mistake this one should be renamed et
cetera et cetera et cetera
we've got to filter it down so that at
the end of it
our users don't get bad auto completes
with stupid contexts in them
right and and yes it's it's significant
work to go through whatever it is i'm
guessing four
different contexts but that work has got
to be done
so i'm just saying we can start it by
looking at what are all the contexts
mentioned
i mean i think there's an easy approach
yeah you know so there's a whole bunch
of contacts that come out of building
the mx files
yeah we can grab those programmatically
at the end of the mx build
fine and those those are what and those
are what see
the internal exclusion list right well
here we go
and then the other set of things that
i've seen you know emails from stephen
about recently i think they were
all contacts that were coming out of
paclets okay
basically basically the goal for the i
mean
we've sort of added a mechanism where
paclets can add themselves to the
internal list
and maybe we will somehow and you know
there's been talk
of maybe the packet manager
automatically does
this or that's what i was going to
suggest
that you know by default you know
we change the packet manager to
blacklist things
and you have to specifically in the
packet info file
say if it shouldn't that's a good idea
talk to todd about it all right maybe
that
maybe those two things will get almost
everything okay we need to move on
because we've got some other stuff to
cover today
um okay so i think
we're good with that but let's make sure
we take it all right so
so but but yes but we didn't actually
discuss any of the
things that were on this list okay so
there are
two uh sort of
so one edge case is should system be
considered internal
um and so this is an edge case because
you know
i understand the issue i understand the
issue right
i mean in a perfect world we would white
list symbols that are
we whiteness things
that are intended to be user set which
are in guide pages about system
configuration
not just uh
derivative is is not okay fine there's a
limited
set that we could white list in a
perfect world we would white list those
i think the default of of of
blacklisting everything
is okay but i suggest that it will be
good if we could white list some of them
in the automatic setting for for
excluded contexts
right except you you notice the
fundamental contradiction in what you've
just said
what that excluded context
talks about which context to exclude and
you're talking about white listing
specific symbols
and i don't know how well fine fine i
don't know how we do that okay fine but
but look excluded context as a first cut
excluding system seems okay to me
except is that going to have some
consequence if you exclude system in
full definition is that going to have a
consequence for parallel computing and
but
uh and for the cloud cloud deploy and so
on
right so that's right well
what's the answer to that i don't know
the answer which is why i was saying
that's why yan is here
okay so maybe you can do that and i'm
here
if you let me speak and i'm not sure if
i have a full answer either but
i am personally not i don't enjoy that i
was the person who who dealt with that
stuff
what's that it's it's not so much about
how that stuff is built it's really what
you're using it for
nobody will will have the definite
answer for that but
i'm i'm personally not too concerned
concerned about that if i deploy
something to the cloud
i would not expect that to pick up these
various
overrides that are made for system
symbols i don't agree with you i think
you would expect that if you
if you have a function that says
if you've defined a derivative
and then you do something then you cloud
deploy something else which depends on
that derivative
you will be upset that that definition
is not pulled along
right that's what i'm worried about i
know i think it's a concern
look personally i mean i would say
it's even more concerning in parallel
computing right
let me make a practical suggestion let's
not change this with 12.2
this is too late in the cycle let's
change this at the beginning of the next
cycle
and see what happens okay so you
so you're saying don't change anything
right now
so so we we basically
uh basically we change
the the the default excluded context to
be
empty list for 12.2 okay
listen listen listen look look steven
we've already made a change so uh
don't don't don't make a change when was
the change made
uh just before the freeze
because it was supposed to be made two
months ago and due to miscommunication
it didn't happen until just before the
freeze let's let's back it out
okay it's too dangerous to change to
make at this point in the cycle
let's make it for the beginning of the
next cycle and see what happens
okay
sorry i'm confused i don't see that
extended full definition
of a symbol for which i've given it a
derivative
value reflects the derivative value so i
don't see that
derivative would be broken by this
change
okay guys guys it's really simple it is
too late in the cycle
to make a change of this type okay it
has too many bizarre consequences
in terms of how things get deployed
let's not do it it's not necessary
it's not been a disaster what we have
right now let's not make that change
and break a bunch of things let's make
it the beginning of the next cycle and
see what happens
okay okay and let's move on
geometric assertion
then are you here
he said he might have to step out for a
moment
i just finished up but i was needed so
then it's yours okay right okay can we
crisply get through the rest of the
stuff here guys i've got
okay okay i sent you i sent you three
inputs and
look and then you see the problem
you sent them no i don't have them no
sorry
so okay i don't know why we all right i
mean the point is basically
i mean i think everything we need to
discuss is right here i'm not sure why
we need
these examples although if they will be
useful we can
discuss them right now geometric
assertion just sits there
um okay so the question is
well okay so no no this is in 12-2 it
evaluates if this is 12-2 it will
evaluate
okay that that didn't evaluate in my
twelve two i don't
know why uh then i don't want the last
one to happen because
it loses all meaning once it has
happened and
well i'm not sure i don't three could be
zero et cetera et cetera et cetera
they're not only right
no no no no no no no i i well for you
know i don't think any of these should
evaluate
right hold on hold on let me understand
the previous situation the previous
situation in 12
1 was none of them evaluated is that
correct correct
okay all right so the next
question is we have assertions like this
where we want them to evaluate we want
to be able to ask are these things
collinear right so
what is but it's not obviously the
dysfunction is right i try to
i i agree okay i agree but geometric
assertion has many second arguments it
has a pretty complicated language right
okay right so what you're saying is
so there are two questions one is um
to have another function parallel to
geometric assertion
which evaluates another is to have a
wrapper around geometric assertion
right so we already have a wrapper
around geometric assertion which is
geometric scene
no that's not a good answer that's not a
good answer why is that not a good
answer because it's a ridiculous thing
to determine whether
three points a co-linear you say
geometric scene of geometric assertion
it's crazy but but in general you won't
know right you the geometric
assertion doesn't have all the
information it may need which you could
supply
via geometric scene um
right if all the points are concrete
then sure
although i will point out we have
collinear points now
so in fact we have this function
um for for this specific case um
right but so what about okay so we have
a function called linear points
but now what about all the other things
here
the the answer that used geometric scene
is not an acceptable answer we need
right
well well we talked about points we
talked about having a
geometric solve
that could well geometric solve
we're is going into the function
repository and is doing something
slightly different
that's um that's more for solving for
a quantity out of the scene like you're
given a geometric
scene and you want to know a formula for
some radius okay what would happen if we
made reduce
take geometric assertions
uh
well i think adam would be unhappy is
the short answer
um right i mean it doesn't does it well
it would um
we could probably make that work um
right i mean it wouldn't make
sense over uh
right since the default domain well
maybe it could
interpret these as being automatically
over the reals because it's geometric
assertion
yeah that's what that's what i would
suggest
is that rather than having all of these
functions you know is it parallel to
perpendicular et cetera et cetera
um
i was thinking about resolve too i'm not
i think the source is near
in spirit okay uh well isn't resolve
about resolving quantifiers and we have
no quantifiers here
that's why i didn't say it i initially
thought resolve is the better concept
but then i thought but it's specific to
quantifiers i mean i i would have no
problem with like
simplify or full simplify taking these
but also they get vastly bigger so they
are not simpler
well then it will function expand yeah
i think we could make function expand as
a courtesy take these
but i think the main documented thing
should probably be something like reduce
i think we should also look at going
forward how many of these we actually
want to turn into things
like our uh you know colonial points
function mm-hmm
because i think quite a few of the other
you know by the time these things have
been being used for 2000 years in euclid
they probably are well established
[Music]
okay so i think that's what we should do
for this one okay
so somebody talk to adam and see whether
he freaks out about this
okay okay
right so there was this text string
suggestion and i don't think we need it
because we
for one thing we we already have basin
code
comma base 16 which does
the you know no space no
what is that what is the objective here
for hex string
so it's basically to represent to show
to convert it to binary data to stream
and use it in places where we show it to
users for example
um infobox or
return of the video
okay and how do you what format do you
want to use
so there are so i need some options for
example
i'd like to have spaces or
work it's lowercase between what between
uh two letter chunks right
spaces or columns these are common
things
okay well so so right now we have base
n code
right so base decode what will handle
all three of these
it'll turn take all three of these
specifications okay so the issue is
where the base
n code will generate those as outputs
right and right the whole reason why we
had a basin code rather than a
base64 encode was that we could have a
whole
zoo of different so let's let's
let's start populating the zoo we've got
all kinds of exotic animals to put in it
yeah but my claim is i don't want to so
i want a specific function with the
options
and i look at the code of base and code
and
adding an option uh to this i don't
think i don't think we want to add
options
and i don't know why why
you know i don't know why adding the
option
is is better than just using the zoo so
we have a base 16 spaces
and a 16 colons base 16 columns
uppercase base 16 columns
lowercase okay what options would you
propose to add
so it's basically uppercase lowercase
and separator yeah good luck
what what do we have symbols for those
no
right so we are introducing a whole
giant new thing for the sake of having
uppercase letters no we don't have an
option for example for refill
but uh it's just secondary ripple why is
riffle relevant
well you yeah if you have chunks of
strings you can reform with
a string of space so
david but look let's be clear by the
time you're giving a complicated enough
specification
you might as well just write a function
it's not exactly hard to do it
yeah it's one liner which i write all
the time so that's
basically okay well fine but let's name
the things that we want
um right so i i forget the right
decision
it defaults to uppercase right so if we
want to add uh
right we could have a base 16 lower case
right that doesn't make sense for
four for base 64 and basically because
they used
default to lowercase or uppercase it
defaults to uppercase
is that the right thing
it's well it's what
uh the wxf library does by default i
i guess we can ask rob and
what do people usually do in base64
well base64 uses both upper and
lowercase letters
so there is no uppercase or lowercase
so i'm sorry so this is base16 we're
talking about only base16
and i and i've see i think people i
think the upper case is more common but
i i won't claim to have done a 2016
classes
yeah in cryptography it's all lowercase
mostly
and sometimes i thought lowercase was
the modern form
i thought uppercase was what people did
when they were thinking about fortran
cards
yeah pretty much i think it should be
lowercase by default
well that's i think
an easy enough change
um i think we should make it lower case
by default and what i think we should do
is we should call it
um i i think
all of the okay look i think i i'm
suggesting it would be
base 16 would be lowercase
no spaces base 16
upper would be
uppercase no spaces right base 16
spaces would be
well actually
i think it should be base 16 pairs
base 16
colon pairs with my suggestion
and base 16 pairs is the
space one and colon pairs is the obvious
thing
yep could it be list base 16 pairs
comma delimiter
yeah i probably could be that would make
more sense yep
well i think those colon pairs is a
it's a good thing to do but i think we
could have an additional
variant which is base 16
pairs
delimiter
seems reasonable to me
mind you implement and document
constantine
okay and i will send you this as some
as email
okay and we made it just in time here
okay all right talk to you all soon
thanks a lot thanks hey michael do you
have a sec